he's closing in on a ton of gym tailors
records and his next touchdown would
time with sterling sharp for third most
touchdowns total in a packers season he
is one of our friends of the program
Aaron Jones back here how are you Aaron
I'm doing good rich I like to send my
condolences out to you you and your
family and let you know you're in my
prayers as well
Oh Thank You Aaron I appreciate that and
I appreciate you call him back because I
couldn't I couldn't answer your call on
Friday and that means a lot to me for
you to say that so thank you I greatly
appreciate it welcome let's let's talk a
little bit of football Aaron are you
even surprising yourself at all um no
sir I would say not at all this is
something I worked all my life for
putting putting this hard work this
offseason do what kind of offense I was
coming into with Coach Lafleur sat down
with him and talked to me in Jamal and
showed us on film what kind of facts
he's had and in this kind of system and
what we could potentially do and so I
just focused and set my goals and knew
what I had to do to take my game to the
next level what are your goals what were
your goals
I don't legally and Russian lead the
league and touchdown pretty much every
statistical category I wrote it back to
lead the league in and come all-pro make
the Pro Bowl and win the Super Bowl well
I mean how much Super Bowl talk is being
had in your locker room right now Aaron
OH none at all our focus was on Monday
night against Minnesota one game at a
time and because we want the playoffs to
run through Green Bay we feel like we
have a great home field I've managed so
we get our job done we take care of
business and we'll set ourselves up well
you know that said Aaron Jones here in
the Rich Eisen show the series that the
NFL Network has every year called
America's game at the outset of a season
where they sit down with the Super Bowl
champions from the previous year and
it's an amazing documentary that
everybody obviously would want to be
part of because that means you've won
the Super Bowl
every single one of those documentaries
talks about not the big moments usually
but it's the moments where adversity
hits every single team has it I'm
wondering how that loss in San Francisco
to the 49ers sat with you guys and is
still sitting with you oh it does this
uh ugly taste in our mouth and how he's
still got a ugly taste from it even
though we've gotten a couple wins after
that we you you move on but you don't
forget about losses like that oh he said
we didn't perform well on that game well
we know we didn't perform what I came in
there's a lot of things we did to hurt
ourselves they affected the game
negatively so we know we could possibly
be facing them later on down the line so
we just gotta focus on ourselves and
continue to get better every day well
your coach even took himself to task
after the game of not getting the ball
into your hands enough and Aaron Rodgers
I would say the other Aaron on the team
haha bore the brunt of it when you heard
that what how did you take that when you
heard that Oh II just I kind of soak on
a bad one I mean on I felt like you I
could have done some things just didn't
have the opportunity um so I thought I
could help my team but at the end of the
day when I got the ball in my hands I
did without what I could do and to put
my team in the position to win so just
hope we get in that situation next time
and make plays okay how do you think
your team's being overlooked in the
conversation about the NSE yeah
um tell me you're not on really pay
attention to what everybody else is just
saying so I don't know you could tell me
if we're being overlooked you are I'll
be honest with you look we're just
focusing on ourselves one one one day at
a time and uh Shawn just trying to
finish out the week 17 and see where
that puts us in a playoff picture so uh
we're gonna keep keep getting these wins
no matter how they come and we'll earn
people's respect one way or another
Aaron Jones here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you you obviously know what the
Vikings are bringing to the equation
here
what's the biggest challenge for you on
this big Monday night game where you
could wrap things up in a considerable
way in the NFC North with a W here oh
you know just I mean they haven't lost
that arm this year and they they fly
around you can tell they're comfortable
flying at home in on defense you can
look on the on film last week they were
flying around there everywhere getting
the ball out so I just feel like the big
key is the ball protecting the ball and
on defense taking away the ball okay and
then what is your relationship with
Rogers the two irons what do you guys
talk about when you get together we talk
about everything from movies to a
different so we have the same birthday
so I really that I did not eleven years
apart so just just everything where was
you at on this day at this time like
kind of seeing how young guy was and
different things and he still calls me
kid and I still call him sir so oh sure
we have he do he keeps me going he keeps
me motivated and he does he keeps me
confident as well I mean he keeps me
going how does he keep you confident I
just continue to stay on my ear a you
can do this all right kid come on this
dish you're dry right here let's go and
just it just gets me going when you have
your quarter but when you have a future
hall-of-famer in your ear every play I
tell you this it makes you think yeah I
couldn't do with this and I mean I know
I can do this so it just gives it a
little bit more added so when he says
this is your drive right here I mean at
what what yard line is he normally
saying that to you on Eric Oh like when
we get down to the red zone he knows
he's about to hand it off to me at the
play something like hey come on this is
get in kid this is your play or come on
kid I like all my four-minute hey kids
finish the sausages your jaw's Bryce I
just that's that must be pretty cool for
a kid from YouTube getting into the
huddle and then there's Aaron Rodgers
saying I believe in you that that must
be pretty damn powerful huh
oh yes it is pretty powerful went on you
come from playing the game so long and
you you hear all the negative critics
about yourself and just how like not a
lot of people believed in you so you get
to this point and one of the most one of
the best quarterbacks in the world
believes in you when other people didn't
and it's just like this guy saw it and
that's all that matters
yeah Davante Adams coming back as you
had to have changed things as well to me
it seems obvious but I'm wondering if
you from Aaron Jones being such a
crucial cog of this offense what what
that meant to get him back from that toe
injury and up in speed no oh it means a
lot of it takes pressure off of me hey
rod everybody I mean you can't just
focus on one player he stretches the
field he's a big play guy he can he can
go deep he can hit the home run any any
play and so you can't just focus on the
running game if you if you want to focus
on that it will play action you can go
over the top so he makes it easier for
everybody okay what movies do you talk
about with Aaron Rodgers what movies and
TV shows
oh we talk about everything from Mighty
Ducks just everything water boy
everything I got to tell you Aaron out
of all the movies that I thought you'd
spit back at me first I didn't think
Mighty Ducks would be that one I gotta
be honest is that your is that your
favorite sports movie is Mighty Ducks
would that be it all right no actually I
was actually with my favorite one of my
favorite movies sports movies is a six
man in glory road but um I was a wearing
a Mighty Ducks Jersey to one of the
games and that's how the conversation
got caught up about it in he made a
quote not and I finished the line on the
clothes though I was pretty funny it's a
stick and water boy that's that's a
pretty damn big one not that no that's a
good fellow right there for sure hey
Aaron you know you were here in studio
over the summer I believe and I always
enjoy our chats I just enjoy watching
you play I tried to get you in fantasy I
couldn't get you you've beaten me twice
in fantasy this year it was not fun that
game against the Dallas Cowboys I wanted
you to stop it was just too damn much
had to be big for you in the state of
Texas that had to be a dream for you oh
it definitely was going back home the
closest I'll get to plan it to El Paso I
had about 30 30 family members there my
brother was there the front row and
actually seeing him was going out on the
hill and I've seen after all right well
right before school one of my test I was
seen I seen him signal throw me the ball
when like when you score and it's just I
was like all right and saw a score sure
enough and he's right there and I
flicked it up to him it was one of the
best best ones in the world one of my
favorite memories as well you deserve it
man you deserve it ace try and stay warm
oh that felt like it iced when I saw I
was sitting in the studio on Sunday
feels like seven that's what it said
four for the temperature feels like
seven did it feel like seven to you this
weekend I know I actually thought a
little bit warmer is kind of funny in
Green Bay the Sun comes out for the game
and right after the game it goes away so
it felt a little bit warmer that's the
football gods man and it certainly helps
to have two rushing touchdowns multiple
rushing touchdowns in four or more games
in a single season you are on the heels
of some pretty long time greats for the
Green Bay Packers Congrats on what
you've done so far and let's chat down
the line okay Erin yes sir thank you I
appreciate I appreciate you for having
me now anytime that's Aaron Jones
Packers running back for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app